geico changed the game when it came to
what an insurance company could pull off
with its commercials
things started off simple enough in the
90s with a talking gecko trying to sell
insurance policies
and it only took off from there soon you
had sleeping beauty and cavemen getting
into the mix with the latter characters
becoming popular enough to warrant their
own television series
the show flopped hard but it's still
impressive that it even got to that
stage
other insurance agencies followed suit
with allstate giving us mayhem to
illustrate how property damage can occur
in a moment's notice
meanwhile progressive has seen great
success with its dr rick commercials
depicting why it isn't always a good
thing when you start turning into your
parents
oh you should still have a good
insurance policy still geico remains the
king of silly insurance commercials
their latest ad spot finds a woman in
her kitchen learning that you can save
hundreds of dollars by switching to
geico seems pretty straightforward right
well things only get stranger from there
with the introduction of a legendary
hip-hop duo who show the woman how to
make a delicious dessert while the name
of the duo may not be familiar to you
their most popular song is recognizable
to pretty much every single person on
the planet
after the requisite geico can save you
money ad copy things quickly turn
hilarious when the announcer asks
so what are you waiting for hip hop
group tag team to help you plan dessert
as you could then surmise the 1990s duo
tag team pop up on queue to perform an
ice cream themed parody of their hit
song whoop there it is
affectionately retitled scoop there it
is in the commercial it seems no
birthday wedding or bar mitzvah is
complete without whoop there it is
making an appearance on the playlist
it's the kind of song that perfectly
encapsulates a kind of family-friendly
hip-hop that went mainstream in the
early 90s
and it continues to be beloved by new
generations to this day in part thanks
to appearances in movies like d2 the
mighty ducks and elf the song was one
hit wonder tag team's only big hit
but they're probably not beating
themselves up too much a report in
smithsonian magazine reveals that the
rappers make up to seventy thousand
dollars a year each in royalties from
this tune alone and when it gets used in
something like a geico ad
the cash register noise in their heads
only gets louder following the release
of their debut album the pair had one
more record in them with 1995's audio
entertainment but the lp didn't have the
same kind of hit single they enjoyed the
first time around
however when you knock it out of the
park the first time around you don't
need a sequel
by the looks of this geico dessert
commercial tag team's still having fun
with their famous hit but where did this
weird little
catchphrase come from as chronicled by
people magazine in 1993 the song has its
roots and a catchphrase that gained
popularity in atlanta dance clubs before
spreading to chicago bulls games and
eventually catching on with the nation
at large
the saying was so popular in fact that
there was some disagreement over which
version was proper
some said whoop while others pronounced
it woot hip-hop group 95 south even
released their own hit single titled
woot there it is
one month before tag team dropped whoop
the dueling groups remained good-natured
in the rivalry which came
to a head when talk show host arsenio
hall invited 95 south and tag team to
face off live on his stage
viewers called in via paid phone line to
vote for their preferred jam
with the proceeds going to flood relief
the surprising part looking back
is at 95 south and their woopsong
actually won the contest
but nearly three decades later with this
geico ad fresh in our minds we have a
feeling we know exactly which group is
actually whooping all the way to the
bank
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
90s nostalgia are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one